CHRIS DEFAY: Welcome,
everyone.
My name is Chris DeFay, I am a
member of the Talks at Google
team here at Google
Los Angeles.
And we're very pleased to have
everyone here in the audience.
And if you're watching on
YouTube, welcome also.
I'm pleased to introduce
Peter Zuckerman today.
He's a journalist and nonfiction
writer who joins us
to talk about his book, "Buried
in the Sky." He's
written an incredibly engaging
book about one of the most
dramatic disasters in alpine
history, a 2008 climb of K2.
Zuckerman interviewed the
Sherpas, survivors, and others
to capture what happened and
to tell this amazing story
from a fresh perspective.
Please join me in welcoming
Peter Zuckerman.
PETER ZUCKERMAN: Can
you hear me OK?
Thanks for having me.
I bet you there are not
many books that in the
acknowledgements actually
thank Google Documents.
This entire book was written
in Google Docs.
I have a collaborator, a
co-author, who lives in Spain.
And this book sincerely would
have been possible without
Google Documents.
So thank you if you're
one of the people who
helped create that.
This project had started
three years ago.
I had a comfortable job at the
"Oregonian," which is the
largest newspaper in the
Pacific Northwest.
And I got a call from
my cousin and
she was really upset.
She called me and she told me
her really good friend had
just died in this mountaineering
disaster.
And she said, Peter, we have
to find out what happened.
And I've got this great idea.
You'll go, you'll fly to
Pakistan, you'll fly to Nepal.
We'll write a book and
everything will be terrific.
And we'll have this
great success.
And I said no, that sounds
like a terrible idea.
I'm not a mountaineer, and I
wasn't sure I wanted to be
trekking around villages that
are technically off limits to
journalists in Nepal.
I also wasn't sure it was safe
to be a gay Jewish-American
trekking through regions of
Northern Pakistan that have
been infested by terrorists or
Taliban, at least, and that
the US embassy had warned
me in a very long letter
to stay away from.
We didn't have a publisher and
I'd have to quit my job.
And I'd have to interview
people who--
I honestly had no idea if
anybody would be interested in
talking to them.
This book just sounded
like a terrible idea.
So I said no, I'm not going
to do this book.
But I agreed to look
into the story.
I've always loved adventure
stories.
And the 2008 disaster on K2--
K2 is a mountain between
China and Pakistan--
it was one of the
most dramatic.
It was life and death, the
limits of human endurance,
it's triumph and tragedy on a
peak that's so lethal most
mountaineers consider
it suicide.
And I'm researching this and
I'm seeing photos-- and you
see the photos in the book--
of people right before they
died, or right before they
made big decisions that led
to people living or dying.
I felt like you saw people at
their most elemental level.
The characters were
larger than life.
They were the kind of
people you do not
bump into every day.
It takes a unique kind of
personality to climb up what
many people consider
the world's
most dangerous mountain.
And the characters were often
very difficult people.
And they're trapped inside the
same tents, and they clash
with each other when their lives
depend on them getting
together, or getting
along together.
And you think who they are and
then right when things get
really bad, they turn out
to be somebody else.
And there are characters that
put me in their shoes and I
thought they would put readers
in their shoes.
They make you ask yourself
what you would do under
similar circumstances.
I mean, are you the kind of
person who, when things get
bad, do you go out there
and rescue people?
Do you hang back?
Would you rescue somebody if
they were from a different
country and they spoke a
different language and didn't
have a lot of money?
It makes you ask yourself what
kind of person you are.
And so I thought, OK.
It's a compelling story
with characters that
really draw me in.
But I just felt like that still
wasn't enough to do a
book-- but there are plenty of
adventure stories about people
trying to make it
up a mountain.
And what really appealed to me,
and what really got me to
do this book, is that it
illustrates a much more
universal problem, a problem
that we face nearly every day,
all the time.
Let me explain what
I mean by that.
Amount mountaineers, there
are the Sherpas.
The Sherpas hold this nearly
mythical status.
They have the seemingly
superhuman ability to do some
of the most dangerous and
difficult climbing.
On a commercial expedition they
scout the routes, they
break the trail, they
fix the ropes.
They establish the camps, they
make the food, they take the
climbers to the summit.
They snap the photo that runs
in all the newspapers of the
person on the summit.
They rescue their client when
they fall and slip.
And this is their job.
It's to safely get their
client up and down the
mountain, their often more
celebrated clients.
And their stories
are rarely told.
In some of the most famous
adventure stories of all time,
their names aren't even
included, or it's just one
line and you don't really
know who they are.
And they're the unsung heroes
of some of the most famous
adventure stories.
And that got me thinking that
we usually tell history
through the eyes of the kings
and the Columbuses, not from
the perspective of the help.
And mountaineering shows how
this kind of omission can lead
to a disaster.
That when your life hangs
from a knot, you need to
know who tied it.
You need to know if it
was tied correctly
When you are putting together
a team of people to lead you
up a mountain, you need to know
very basic things about
those people, like whether they
speak the same language.
And whether they are business
and ethnic rivals who will
work together, and want
to work together,
and can work together.
And when you tell an
incomplete story--
when you tell a story that omits
crucial perspectives,
what you fail to learn can
lead to a disaster.
And worse yet, you might not
even find out what really
happened, what the
consequences of
your actions were.
And people will keep repeating
your errors.
And these were major issue
on K2 in 2008.
So for the rest of us, for
those of us who aren't K2
mountaineers, I feel like we're
largely in the same situation.
That we all hang from knots that
other people have tied.
That we all have mountains to
summit, and that we're all
surrounded by people
we rarely notice.
You think of a person who
prepares your food at a
restaurant or the cafeteria, and
the last mechanic to check
the plane before take off, or
the nurse who sterilizes the
syringe before an injection.
This book dramatizes the fact
that there are Sherpas, that
there are people we often
overlook all around us.
And we cannot afford to ignore
them, that the Sherpas of
every story need to be seen
for whom they really are
because our lives
depend on them.
That, to me, seemed like a good
reason to write a book.
And that's how I decided
to do it.
And so I quit my job--
and it was a nice job.
And I dove into it and I flew
off, first to Nepal.
And I quickly learned that doing
journalism in South Asia
is not at all like doing it
in the United States.
And I'll give you some
examples of that.
When I arrived in Kathmandu,
I learned that almost every
Sherpa has one of seven names.
It's the day of the week they
were born, male or female.
So everybody born on Monday
is named Dawa.
And everybody born on Tuesday
is Mingma and everybody born
on Wednesday is Lhakpa,
all the way up to
Sunday, which is Ngima.
And the last--
and there are some variations
to that, but there
are not that many.
And for a last name almost
all the Sherpas
use the name Sherpa.
So this system kind of works
in a really small village,
where everybody knows
each other.
And you can say, Monday,
the daughter of Monday.
But in a city--
honestly it's just
dysfunctional.
Phone books don't help.
Gossipers have to provide these
elaborate descriptions
of the people they're
maligning.
The nicknames abound, but
names have power.
And you're not going to tell
an outsider your nickname.
You're probably not going to
tell many people at all.
And so tracking down the
right person, just
figuring out who--
which Pasang Sherpa out of the
20,000 Pasang Sherpas who live
in the same neighborhood, which
one is the one you're
looking for, really
was a challenge.
And then there were
the villages.
To do this research I had
to go to villages that--
you know, getting there--
I think people have been places
that don't have phones,
or electricity, or
running water, or
antibiotics, or petroleum.
But getting to a lot of the
villages-- there were no
roads, there was no metal, there
was very little or, I
don't know if there
was any machinery.
And it could take weeks
to get there.
You would go from the
nearest air strip.
You would just start
backpacking.
And at each village the
languages were--
by some anthropologists
considered each language at
each village a separate
language.
And so you would have to find
a translator who could speak
the language there and a common
language with the team
of translators I was with, to
try to translate to English,
so I could understand
what was happening.
And just to be honest, sit down
interviews really didn't
work that well.
I would ask questions like,
how old are you?
And it would go through
two translators.
How old are you?
And there would be a little
discussion between two of the
people, and then between
the two translators.
And then finally I would get an
answer that was like I was
born during the Buddha's
corn festival.
I'd say, oh, what
year was that?
I realized that the questions
that I asked just didn't
always make sense.
And so to do the research, I
realized at least for the
significant interviews, this was
going to take a long time.
But getting places was also
So I just did the interviews by
trekking with the people I
was interviewing.
So like, while we were in route
from one village to the
next, we would just
go as a big group.
And I would just interview
people all day, every day, for
weeks at a time.
And that was-- and with
the main characters, a
lot longer than that.
And that was how we were finally
able to get the story.
And so my point in telling you
all this is that I don't think
there's a conspiracy to hide
the story of the Sherpas.
I think it's just a really
challenging story for
reporters on a deadline
to be able to get.
We say in the book that we
research for two years and
that we took seven
trips to Nepal.
But then we ended up taking nine
trip to Nepal because we
had to go back and we wanted
to fact check everything to
make sure we got it right.
We also took three trips
to Pakistan,
which is where K2 is.
And I'll talk about
the Pakistanis
climbers as well, here.
And we got unprecedented
access to military and
government officials.
Nazir Sabir, who was a
politician and the president
of the alpine club, went
all out to get
us incredible access.
In total we interviewed more
than 200 people at length.
We also spent countless hours
at kitchen tables in France,
Holland, Ireland, Italy,
Norway, Serbia, Spain,
Switzerland and the
United States.
And we relied on more than 1,000
photographs and videos.
This is from Pakistan and we're
going across a bridge.
And at first these bridges look
really scary, but you get
used to them, actually,
after a while.
But it gives you an idea
of what some of
the area looked like.
You're probably wondering now,
what is this book about?
And I'm going to jump
right into it.
It's about a mountaineering
disaster.
And the disaster lasted
27 hours.
And I'm going to read us an
excerpt that's from a scene
that occurs a little bit less
than halfway through.
"Hanging off the face of a
cliff, an ice axe the only
thing between him and death, a
Sherpa climber named Chhiring
Dorje swung to the left.
A massive ice boulder
ripped off above,
hurtling toward him.
It was the size of
a refrigerator.
The underbelly caught,
and the mass flipped,
cartwheeling down.
It tore past, skimming
Chhiring's
shoulder, then vanished.
Brooof.
It slammed into something
below, shattering.
The mountain ship
with the impact.
Powder shot up in a column.
It was near midnight
on August 1, 2008.
Chhiring had only a hazy
idea of where he was--
on or near the Bottleneck of K2,
the deadliest stretch of
the most dangerous mountain.
At roughly the cruising altitude
of a Boeing 737, the
Bottleneck stretched away
from Chhiring into
the darkness below.
In the star light, the channel
seemed bottomless as wisps of
fog slithered into the abyss.
Above, a lip of ice curled
like the barrel
of a crashing wave.
Oxygen depletion had turned
Chhiring's mind to mush.
Hunger and exhaustion
had broken his body.
When he opened his mouth, his
tongue froze; when he gasped
for breath, the moistureless
air scoured his throat and
lashed his eyes.
Chhiring felt robotic, cold,
too tired to think of what
he'd sacrificed to get to K2.
The Sherpa mountaineer, who had
summited Everest 10 times,
had been consumed by
K2 for decades.
A far more difficult peak than
Everest, K2's summit is one of
the most prestigious prizes
in mountaineering.
Chhiring had gone despite his
wife's tears, despite the
climbing costing more money than
his father had made in 40
years, despite his Buddhist
lama warning him that K2's
goddess would never tolerate
the climb.
Chhiring had made it to the
summit of K2 that evening
without using bottled oxygen,
vaulting him into an elite
group of the most successful
mountaineers.
But the descent wasn't turning
out as planned.
He had dreamed of the
achievement, a heroic
reception, even fame.
None of that mattered now.
Chhiring had a wife, two
daughters, a thriving business
and a dozen relatives
who depended on him.
All he wanted to do was
get home alive."
So Chhiring--
he's on the Botteneck of K2.
That's an excerpt from
the prologue.
And he can't afford to slip
because it turns that the
fixed ropes, the ropes that he
was relying on to get down--
they have been torn out by
a chunk of falling ice.
Nobody saw.
It was too dark to see it , it
might have been the size of
this building.
It might have the
size of a bus.
But it had been shredded.
And so he's coming down the
Bottleneck of K2, you know,
this wall of ice.
And he encounters
another climber
who others have passed.
This climber, Pasang Lama, has
lost his axe, his ice axe,
which is a crucial piece
of equipment.
It's basically impossible to
climb down a wall of ice with
no rope and no ice axe.
And so Pasang is stranded.
He's actually from a different
ethnic group, who the Sherpas
often consider rivals.
He's on a different team and
he's preparing to die.
And Chhiring decided to do what
in some ways just seems
both heroic and kind
of insane.
He takes out a piece of rope
from his from his pack, maybe
an arm length or two across.
And he ties it on to Pasang.
And they go down, they start
going down, the deadliest
stretch of the most dangerous
mountain with Pasang literally
hanging off Chhiring.
So that's where I'm going
to pick up the excerpt.
"Rocks and chunks of
ice spun at them,
dinging their helmets.
But they were halfway down and
thought they'd survive.
The night was windless, minus
4 degrees Fahrenheit, almost
warm for K2.
The lights of high camp
were smoldering below.
Chhiring and Pasang didn't
expect it to happen.
A chunk of ice or rock knocked
Pasang on the head.
Batted off the ice, he
swung like a pinata.
The force of Pasang's body
on the rope peeled
Chhiring from the slope.
The men tore downward.
Chhiring gripped his axe with
both hands and slammed it into
the mountain.
The blade wouldn't catch.
It cut surgically through
the snow.
Sliding faster, Chhiring heaved
his chest against the
adz of his axe, digging
into the slope.
No good--
Chhiring fell faster, another
seven yards, another ten.
Pasang punched the slope with
his fists and tried to grip,
but his fingers skated
along the ice.
Chhiring and Pasang, as they
fell into the darkness, must
have wondered, how
did this happen?"
Part of what attracted me to
this story was that initial
question, how did this happen?
But to dig deeper, I had to get
answers to tougher questions.
And I'm going to read and
excerpt that gives you a sense
of what I mean by that.
"Many of the alpinists consider
themselves to be
among the best in the world.
Some had risked everything
to scale K2.
Their climb had devolved
into a catastrophe.
The final toll was bleak.
Within 27 hours, 11 climbers
had died in the deadliest
single disaster in K2 history.
What had gone wrong?
Why had the climbers continued
up when they knew they'd never
make it down before nightfall?
How had they made so many
simple mistakes such as
failing to bring enough rope?
The story became an
international media sensation,
landing on the covers of the
"New York Times," "National
Geographic Adventure,"
"Outside," and in more than
1,000 other publications.
It ricocheted around the
blogosphere and inspired
speculation, documentaries, a
stage play revival, memoirs,
and talk shows.
Some considered the climb
an example of hubris.
A waste of life fueled by
machismo or madness, thrill
seekers trying too hard to
get noticed by corporate
sponsorship, lunatics climbing
in a final act of escape,
oblivious Westerners exploiting
the lives of
impoverished Nepalese and
Pakistanis in a bid for glory.
'You want to risk your life?',
a response to one of the "New
York Times" stories said.
'Then do it in service of your
country, or family, or
neighborhood.
Climbing K2 or Everest is a
selfish stunt that benefits
nothing.'
Others saw courage--
explorers pitted against the
adversity of nature, lost
souls embracing risk to find
meaning in an empty world.
'Climbing can expand the view of
human potential for all of
us,' read a letter from Phil
Powers, executive director of
the American Alpine club.
Several people raised
basic questions.
What do men and women do
when they're on top
of a mountain dying?
And why are some people driven
to take such risks?
Before they were trapped on the
mountain top, before the
deaths and funerals, before
the rescues and reunions,
before the fistfights and
friendships, before the
recriminations and
reconciliations, everything
had seemed perfect.
The equipment was checked
and rechecked.
The routes established,
the weather
cooperative, the teams intact--
the moment they had spent so
much time and training and
money to reach, summit date
had finally come.
They were going to conquer K2.
Stand on top of the most vicious
mountain on earth,
howl in triumph, unfurl their
flags, and call their
sweethearts."
I want to give you an
idea of what K2 is.
It's the second tallest
mountain and
here's where it's located.
It's between China
and Pakistan.
This is what it looks like.
It has a much slimmer
profile than
Everest and is much steeper.
This is what it looks like from
the Bottleneck, you're
below or slightly below it.
If you could imagine this
photo's actually looking up.
So that ice there hangs over the
climbers like a balcony.
And the glacier on the mountain
is pushing off chunks
every once in awhile, especially
when the ice is
refreezing at night.
This is the view from the summit
of the Karakoram range.
It hooks into the Himalaya,
it's a younger range.
So it hasn't been chiseled down
as much by the elements,
it's much sharper.
"K2 lacks the mass of Everest,
but it's sleeker and meaner.
Climbers call it the
savage mountain.
Its peak has all the obstacles
of Everest and more.
K2's glaciers are riddled
with fissures concealed
by layers of snow.
Climbers step on these
crevasses, punch through, and
if unroped--
disappear.
Blocks of ice cleave off
overhanging glaciers.
Avalanches roar down
icy flanks.
And then there's the altitude.
No human plant or animal can
tolerate such harsh conditions
for more than a few days.
With each lungful of air,
climbers on the summit suck in
only a third of the oxygen they
breathe at sea level.
Oxygen deprivation saps
their strength and
compromises their judgment.
Altitude illness breaks them,
giving some the coordination
of toddlers.
As if these difficulties weren't
enough, storms are
harsher on K2.
It stands 882 miles northwest of
Everest, and being further
from the equator, is more
vulnerable to unpredictable
extra tropical cyclones
and their
accompanying jet streams.
All of this makes for
dismal statistics.
Before 2008, only 278 people
had stood on K2's summit.
Everest's summit roll was 4,115
and its fatality rate,
the percentage of climbers who
went above base camp and died,
had averaged 0.7% for
the previous decade.
Although the Himalayan database
crunches these
numbers for Everest,
no accurate
statistics exist for K2.
Climbers of the savage mountain
can't reliably
approximate their chances of
survival and don't want to.
In 2008, the fatality rate of
those leaving base camp for a
summit bid was 30.5%, higher
than the casualty rate at
Omaha Beach on D-day.
Among high altitude climbers, if
not statisticians, there's
no comparison.
K2 is more lethal
than Everest."
Here is a photo of the
two main characters.
Last I was reading about them,
they were hanging off the
Bottleneck, off an ice axe in
the Bottleneck sliding down.
Chhiring is the one who had the
ice axe, and Pasang is the
one who was hanging
off of him.
Chhiring is on your
right, my left.
I actually got to bring this
book to Kathmandu and got to
let them see it before
it came out.
So this is them seeing the
book for the first time.
I want to give you a little
flavor of who the characters
are, so I'm going to read
an excerpt that
characterizes Chhiring.
He is the one on your right.
"His walk was more of a jog.
He didn't drive a car, he
rocketed through traffic on a
black Honda Hero motorcycle.
In the seven languages he
spoke conversationally,
Chhiring Dorje Sherpa talked so
quickly it seemed as though
each sentence were one long
word, punctuated by
exclamation points.
Everything about him was
accelerated, his eating, his
thinking, his climbing,
his praying.
He couldn't control the pace.
Speed was hardwired
into his DNA.
His first name meant long life,
but its pronunciation to
English speakers, cheering,
personified him.
Cheerful determination radiated
from Chhiring.
It got him noticed.
Clients praised his, you can
do it, let's rock and roll,
give me your pack attitude.
It was contagious.
How could you sit still at camp
when every few minutes he
would lurch up, stride forward,
chops his arms
through the air, make a
pronouncement, plop down, and
spring up again?
There was a reason was
34-year-old dynamo rarely
drank coffee.
He was caffeinated enough.
'Chhiring was always crazy,'
said his father, Ngawang
Thundu Sherpa.
'He was a naughty child, and
I knew he'd be a naughty
adult.'" Here's Chhiring
on the summit of K2.
Then the other major character
is Pasang,
who is on your left.
And this will be the last
excerpt I'll read, but it
gives you an idea
of who he is.
"A sticker on his helmet labeled
him the Joker, and
Pasang lived up to it.
He smuggled rocks into friend's
sleeping bags,
pillows and packs.
He wrapped pebbles in Tootsie
Roll wrappers and handed them
to children begging for candy.
At night he festooned tents with
branch-and-trash towers.
When the tents' occupants
crawled out in the morning and
the scaffolds crashed down,
Pasang threw back his head,
cackling, and galloped off in
search of his next victim.
When in the city he was
someone different.
He cloaked this happy-go-lucky
personality in an armor of
shyness and caution.
Men like Chhiring bounded
up to newcomers with the
enthusiasm of a Labrador,
no matter the setting.
In Kathmandu, Pasang
couldn't do that.
He hung back, keeping
a safe distance.
When acquaintances opened their
arms for a hug, they
received a handshake.
While eating dinner with a
group of new clients in
Kathmandu, Pasang's body
was at the table.
But his eyes were patrolling
the room, ready to
alert him of danger.
It often took him several
hours to crack
a smile for a stranger.
But when he allowed one,
his grin was sincere.
Compact, stretching just shy of
five foot two, Pasang had
hands as rough as
a cat's tongue.
When he was 24 years old, he
looked 15 and accepted his
nickname, little Pasang.
Clients occasionally doubted
that he was an adult and asked
for, quote, 'another Sherpa with
more experience than this
baby.' To age himself,
Pasang rarely shaved.
But it made no difference.
His chin refused to
grow a beard."
Throughout writing this book
I felt a tremendous
responsibility and respect
for the characters.
Many of them lost their lives,
or saw other people lose their
lives, or had family members
lost their lives.
And they had to do really tough
interviews with me.
And in a way, this story is
a really horrifying story.
But in a way it's also a
really inspiring story.
You see people who started off
in small villages and become
some of the best athletes in the
world, often athletes no
one else has heard of,
but among the best.
And they pull off some feats
that just seem unimaginable.
And so I want to say I'm
grateful to my friends who
helped me see the top of the
world through their eyes,
because without their
willingness, this book would
have been possible.
And my hope is that, when you
read this book, that Amanda
and I have made a small
contribution to the way we
tell stories.
And that this story gives you
a glimpse into yourself, and
helps you recognize and more
deeply appreciate the Sherpas
who are in your life.
Thank you very much, and I'm
happy to answer questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I guess I'll start
with a question about your
decision to write the book.
Where you at all intimidated
by "Into Thin Air?"
PETER ZUCKERMAN: It's one
of those weird things of
publishing is, on the one hand,
there's been a book
that's been extremely popular.
So that shows that, hey,
there might be
room for another book.
On the other hand you're like,
wow, I'm always going to--
like that's what roughly
established the genre.
And I think "Into Thin
Air" s a good book.
I enjoyed it.
I feel like this is sort of
the corollary, where "Into
Thin Air" is a first person
story told from Jon Krakauer's
perspective.
And this is a more--
I don't want to say more
complete, but a more
reporter's account told from the
eyes of the Sherpas, who
do a lot of the-- who, you
know, fix the ropes that
people like Jon Krakauer
were going up.
But yeah, it's a good book.
It's a little bit
intimidating.
AUDIENCE: So I think we can
all agree that the primary
responsibility for making the
poor decisions up on the
mountain belong to the people
that make the decisions.
How much responsibility do you
think the Sherpas should share
for enabling people who may
not be fully prepared or
capable of making the climb to
attempt something that they
maybe shouldn't be doing?
PETER ZUCKERMAN: There's some
fundamental conflicts.
The Sherpas get paid, in part,
based on how many people make
it to the summit.
You get a summit bonus.
So there's a clear incentive,
especially when your families
relying on your income from that
climb for the rest of the
year, or for much of the
rest of the year--
there's a definite incentive
to get your client to the
summit so you get that bonus.
And Sherpas will say, oh, I'm
not going to take someone up
there who's going to die.
But certainly I keep that in
mind when I'm trying to decide
whether or not I need to tell
somebody to turn around.
So that's just-- in my opinion,
I think a better
system would be you pay the
Sherpas based on how many
people make it back alive,
or something like that.
I don't know if that model
has been explored.
And a lot of the decisions just
weren't really decisions.
They were just miscommunication.
The client climbers--
one of the problems of this
disaster is there was one
person who sort of could
translate from the high
altitude workers
to the clients.
And he got trapped down
on a lower camp.
So in a sense, a big part
of the problem was there
was just not much--
there weren't decisions being
made in a strategic way.
It was just sort of lack
of communication.
And then you want to say
well, then why didn't
they just turn around?
And it's hard when you've been--
when you've spent so
much time, and so many years,
waiting for this.
And it's your third attempt at
K2 but the other two seasons
you came the weather just never
opened up, so there was
no chance to even go
for the summit.
And this is your one
last chance to go.
It's really hard.
I'm not saying it's the wrong
decision to turn around.
But it's a really hard decision
to turn around.
So I don't think there's
an easy--
that the blame could be spread
out among the whole, like on
individual decisions,
on cultural lack of
understanding, on a whole
systemic problems.
There's no limit to the number
of people who can climb up all
at once and so overcrowding
is a big contributor.
Do you blame Pakistan
for that?
I don't know.
Or do you blame the climbers who
all want to go up and are
lobbying to let as many
people go up at once.
Or do you say that's a fine
system because that's the most
fair system?
So I don't think there's
a clear answer to that.
AUDIENCE: How are the
professional climbers like you
spoke to-- the Sherpas
who do this--
how are they viewed within
their own community?
Within the Sherpa community,
how are they seen?
Are they seen as
irresponsible, or are they heroes?
PETER ZUCKERMAN: There's
a range.
Some climbers have a terrible
reputation and nobody wants to
work for them.
And in this book there's a
Korean team and Mr. Kim has a
really bad reputation among the
Sherpas, and nobody wants
to work for him.
And so, frankly, the people who
work for him are the ones
who really desperately
need to work.
Their families are really
relying on them and they don't
have that many other options.
And he has--
for libel reasons, there's
some things that I can't
necessarily say that
he's done.
But I would say that he had a
reputation for fighting with
the Sherpas and forcing them to
do things that they thought
were suicide missions.
Then there are other climbers
who really know the Sherpas,
who speak their language
and have really been
advocates for them.
And that have a great reputation
among the Sherpas.
And there's some--
and then there's a current
movement which a lot of the
Sherpas don't like, where the
Western climbers are saying,
we're going to do
this ourselves,
without Sherpa support.
And in a way that's a more
impressive way to climb a
mountain but it's something
that the Sherpas don't
necessarily like because
they lose business.
And so there can be resentment
from the Sherpas.
And the Sherpas aren't
always nice, either.
I would say that the reputations
depend on the
individuals very much, and that
there's a huge range.
AUDIENCE: A kind of interesting
question to me is,
among the Sherpa population
in general--
not every Sherpa villager
does this for a living.
I'm assuming it's a small
minority who actually do this.
It's a hard and dangerous job.
How are the Sherpa
who do this.
how are they viewed within the
larger Sherpa community?
PETER ZUCKERMAN: The view--
I would say the view
is shifting.
During the very early climbs,
the late 1800s, early 1900s,
the mountains--
the gods lived in
the mountains.
And climbing a mountain was a
sin and what you were doing
was going to not just harm you,
it was going to harm your
whole family.
And people--
a lot of people who
went climbing were
really looked down on.
But there's been sort of
a shifting view, where
especially on Mount Everest--
well, Mount Everest's goddess,
she has a gold face.
She flies around on I
forget the type--
is it a zebra?
I forget.
And she's the goddess
of prosperity.
And maybe she makes
an exception.
Because lots of people are
making it up Everest without
getting hurt, lots of people
are getting rich.
So maybe it's OK to climb
Everest if you
make a lot of money.
And so there's been this
growing acceptance of,
climbing is--
maybe it's a really
good profession.
Because you talk to old Sherpas
and they'll say, well,
I used to think it was
really terrible.
But now my son comes home and
look, I got new shoes.
And I have a nice tin roof
over my house here.
And so now I'm thinking
mountaineering's a good thing.
So I would say that there is
a shift in the culture,
happening as we speak.
And it's becoming more
and more acceptable.
And among the youngest people,
my observations where that
they typically thought
mountaineering was fine.
I mean, that's a good way to
make a living, albeit a
dangerous one.
And then I'd say the Sherpa
children born today, they're
getting educations.
And their parents often say, I'm
doing this job so my kids
don't have to have it.
And I should add that Sherpa
is a really complex term.
The Sherpas who live
near Everest say
it's an ethnic group.
The people who live further from
Everest say it's a job
description because people
want to hire a Sherpa.
And then there are the high
altitude workers in Pakistan
who are often called high
altitude porters which can be
a disparaging term in some
people's eyes from
[INAUDIBLE].
And so it's a-- but I think in
Pakistan it's just kind of
what they're called.
And so there's a lot of dispute
over what a Sherpa is,
and a lot of money at stake.
Because people want to hire a
Sherpa, and so everybody says
they're a Sherpa.
And the people who have a
stronger claim of being ethnic
Sherpas say that's not right.
And the people whose lives
depend on Sherpa workers say,
no, it's just a job
description.
And our lives matter too, and
we shouldn't have this
celebrity ethnicity.
AUDIENCE: Could you elaborate
a little bit on what it
typically costs to fund an
expedition of this caliber?
And what a Sherpa could expect
to get for taking those risks?
And also as a second part two,
it sounded like you just kind
of did your research and
then got on a plane.
Maybe talk a little bit about
your journey, did you have to
get sponsors to do
your research?
And kind of what that
process was like.
PETER ZUCKERMAN: It depends
on how you want to climb.
If you want to climb with a huge
team of porters who are
going to bring you a generator
to run your computer, and
serve you really good food
and such, the costs
can get really high.
Especially I'd say the high end
of an Everest expedition
will get $150, $175,000
per person.
It can.
Some people do very bare
bones expeditions.
And on K2 the permit is--
I'm trying to remember what it
is right now, but it's a lot
cheaper than Everest.
It's less than $10,000.
And on K2, if you're just doing
a bare bones expedition
and you're planning to do it all
yourself, I mean I think
you can probably do it
for around $10,000.
Maybe less if you're
really good.
So there's considerable
range in cost.
In terms of the cost of doing
this project, the biggest
expense is getting there.
Getting to Nepal or Pakistan
is several thousand
dollars to get there.
But if you're trekking around
and living in Sherpa villages,
the power of the dollar
goes really far.
And so you can--
I mean it's actually not that
expensive to do the research
once you're there.
The hard part is, I would do the
research and then I would
realize, oh, I should
have done XYZ.
Now I realize this.
I need to go back
and getting back
there is really expensive.
For the initial research, we
paid for it ourselves.
And then we just slept on
people's couches and used
frequent flier miles and
were living in tents.
And then later on, the
book proposal could
help pay for it--
the advance from the
book proposal.
So that's kind of how it
worked financially.
Oh, and the Sherpas get paid
several thousand dollars.
It's maybe $3,000, depending on
how experienced they are, I
would say maybe the
range would be
maybe $1,000 to $5,000.
And there's sort of two
different types of the high
altitude workers, who get paid
a lot more than the low
altitude workers who carry
stuff to base camp.
They don't really get
paid much at all.
The high altitude workers who
can be really skilled, they
can get paid significantly
more.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PETER ZUCKERMAN: What's that?
PETER ZUCKERMAN: Oh,
that's per Sherpa.
That's how much each individual
Sherpa will take in.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PETER ZUCKERMAN: Yeah, I would
say over the whole expedition.
I mean it also depends on
how long the expedition
is going to go for.
If you happen to get lucky and
everybody's acclimatize and
the weather window is right when
you arrive, it's probably
going to be significantly
cheaper.
Because you won't have to
have as much supplies
being ferried in.
AUDIENCE: Recently there was
that altercation between the
Sherpas and the Western
climbers.
And I was wondering if you felt
that your book empowered
the Sherpas?
And if many of the Sherpas
know about your book?
PETER ZUCKERMAN: I would say
we've made a big effort to let
the Sherpas know
about the book.
And the Sherpas have really
liked the book.
They're really happy that their
story has been told.
Most Sherpas who are in
climbing are not as--
I don't want to say most.
But a lot of them, I'll
say, are illiterate.
And we went through the book
page by page with the major
characters who are not
fantastic readers.
But I don't know how much the
Sherpas know about the details
of the book.
But I hope they do.
The fight on Everest--
so there was literally a high
altitude brawl, supposedly, up
on camp three on Everest
recently.
And I don't really know what
to think about that.
I mean, part of me--
the Western climbers were well
respected climbers who knew
what they were doing
and have done a lot
for the Sherpas before.
They continued up when the
Sherpas had told them not to.
But they were on a separate
team and were competent
enough, probably, to keep
climbing on their own.
On the other hand, I've not seen
many detailed interviews
with the Sherpas.
And I haven't interviewed
the Sherpas.
And so I feel like half the
story has not been told yet.
So it's really hard to--
So based on the facts that have
come out, I feel like the
Westerners look really good.
But those facts have mostly
come from the Westerners.
So most of the people
there are still at
Everest base camp.
It's hard to get interviews
there unless you go to Nepal
or people really want to spend
a lot of money on a sat phone
to tell the story
of the Sherpas.
So I think is going to be a
while until the facts shake
out on that.
And then I don't really
know where to blame.
But it's a tough situation.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks
for coming.
You mentioned in story
about the naming.
And then you said that the
language and culture are
disappearing.
So I was curious if you could
tell a couple more interesting
things you found
in the culture?
And what's happening to it.
PETER ZUCKERMAN: Absolutely.
A few really interesting
things--
one, there was--
at a lot of the villages I went
to the elders there told
me, this is where the
world started.
This is the beginning of life.
The beginning of life
was at Rolwaling,
right here at Beding.
And everybody who leaves
is going to die.
And, actually, you need to move
here because you seem
like a good person.
And you need to get all of our
children to move here, because
they're leaving and they're
going to be killed along with
everybody else.
And then the young people
say that story is
completely made up.
They just tell that to
entertain Westerners.
And the dismiss us, because
everybody's leaving these
villages and the festivals are
going away and things just
aren't what they used to be.
So I talked to anthropologists
about this.
And said, well what's
the real story?
They didn't know either.
But it's a really sad.
The village that Chhiring grew
up in used to have several
hundred people.
And when I went there
was just 23 people.
And they were all really old.
And the young people are all
moving to Kathmandu, the city
in Nepal, to take jobs
in mountaineering.
In Pakistan I felt like the
villages were much more--
the villages I went to, they
had a lot more going on and
they still retained a lot
more of the culture.
But in some ways were also going
through that transition
to more people leaving the city
to the Western world.
And I feel like one of the
things I learned from this
project is, on the one hand,
it's easy to characterize.
I come home and I think, gosh,
I live so comfortably.
I'm not going to die of
a contagious disease.
Life is really pretty good for
me and I really have so much.
And I saw how comfortable
my life is.
And then on the other
hand, I thought,
gosh, I have so little.
If I lived in a village I
would know who all my
neighbors were.
And I'd spend a lot more time
drinking tea, and playing
games, and really caring
about my community.
And so I can see how
globalization or whatever you
want to call it is isolating
us as it makes us more
comfortable.
And that's certainly happening
in the villages in a very
dramatic way.
AUDIENCE: So in your
presentation here you talk a
lot about the lessons that go
beyond just this story and
looking outside life.
Is that also themes that
are addressed in
the book itself too?
PETER ZUCKERMAN: A little bit.
I try not to talk too much
about myself in the book.
Because I feel like I learned
all these lessons, but here
people who were dying.
And here are--
I felt like, oh gosh, I had
some crazy adventures.
Like as was mentioned here, long
story, but I overdosed on
a worm with shrooms
growing out of its
head for karma purposes.
And had to be evacuated
on a helicopter.
And it was very scary and
life-changing and strange.
And we are all declared dead and
it was a crazy adventure.
But I feel like that was a
crazy adventure for me.
But the lessons are
more for the--
the climbers had a much more
life and death experience than
I ever did and are much more
courageous people that I was.
I wasn't climbing K2.
That said, and I try to be too
judgmental of them because
it's hard to judge people at
their worst moments when
they're oxygen deprived--
but that said, I tried very
clearly make sure the facts
are in place.
So that somebody reading this
can say, oh, that's how I
think about this situation
and can draw those
lessons from it.
Because I felt like there
are lessons, it's just--
it's hard for me to come up with
a real universal lesson
except, which I feel like is a
really important universal
lesson, is Sherpas are
all around us.
There are Sherpas
in every story.
And you need to know about the
people you're working with
because you depend on them
whether you're trying to climb
up your own mountain, whether
you're climbing up K2.
And I feel like the fundamental
lesson I learned
from this was that it's sort of
a teamwork lesson, which is
know the members of your team.
And that that was something
that more
mountaineers could do.
CHRIS DEFAY: Thank you, Peter.
PETER ZUCKERMAN: Well
thank you very much.
This was fun.
[APPLAUSE]